war is full of uncertainty we strike  when the moon is highest moon shadow  elves are dangerous elite fighters can't  you just make peace with them it's not  that simple there's history with  Rawlings on both sides  humans shut down the king of the Dragons  and destroyed his only egg the dragon  Prince justice will not be denied you  need to see something this changes  everything  maybe it could stop the world it's up to  us now we have to return this egg this  idea get out there and find them I'm  gonna find a way to stop them after all  unstoppable is just another kind of  stoppable no that's not really right  [Music]  [Music]  you  [Music]